we got her out of the car the first
thing she did was chase our then four
year old and he started screaming and
running around he slipped scooted under
my car and hit his head on the bumper he
is out of control out of his mind he
runs up the stairs screaming she freaks
me out take her back she freaks me out
oh my god that was the beginning the
very beginning yeah she bites she nips
we were all bleeding for the first
couple of weeks
she runs or she's jumping on the
furniture we're doing something wrong
and she's attacking our five-year-old
constantly my job is to take care of
Jessie so when she wants to get Jessie
she's gonna go after him and my only way
to stop that is to try to wrangle her
but little Jessie gives as good as he
gets
he teases her you know and they wrestle
and now all she knows is attack with him
she thinks it's just full-on kill the
five-year-old and then just when you
think he's had enough Jessie's had
enough you know he just gets that little
grin he walks outside he sees her and
then old son she just runs and sees him
and they just go on
I think maybe it's her way of playing
but her way of playing hurts not me the
Chewie at first the family tried to seek
refuge in their pool we used to go in
the pool because she was afraid of it
she saw Jessie in there and she would
run and run a dashing - and bark and
bark and it'd be crazy and then one day
she was so crazy with it she actually
fell in and it was her first kind of
taste of the water all of a sudden she
became like a water moccasin
you know the head was just coming with
his teats you know underneath and coming
right at the kids and I'm holding them
down and we're having to take her and
put her in the garage so now she doesn't
even get to be with the kids when we're
all outside so I'm sad for her I feel
responsible there's just too much drama
attached as he gets freaked out by her
violence or whatever and thinks he's in
trouble and then it just kind of
escalates they feed off of each other we
need to do something and then somebody
suggested the dog whisperer
so there you go thank you
personally my hopes are that a miracle
will happen and that dog whisperer will
sprinkle his little dust we were a
family dog yes we don't bet we're just
overwhelmed right now